ah deep dark I know a thing or two about
deep dark in the opening scene we see a
man abruptly Awakening at midnight a
mysterious chain-like object has somehow
been lodged in his belly button after
pulling the entire thing out the man
experiences heavy bleeding prompting him
to cry out loud and panic seconds later
he snaps back to reality revealing that
it was just a nightmare his girlfriend
who is lying beside him seems to be used
to these episodes so she simply ignores
him let me guess babe you dreamed about
the leprechauns again following this we
were introduced to a guy named Herman
who has a dream to become a great and
successful artist his ambition is to
craft extraordinary artworks that would
touch people in the deepest of ways and
make them see things differently for
this he is tirelessly devoted his days
and nights but sadly his masterpieces
are always rejected having spent years
of zero accomplishment Herman's mother
suggests he seek guidance from his uncle
Felix who is a successful Artisan
renowned for his Exquisite earrings how
however Hermann believes that his uncle
is a hack as he exploits his workers for
meager wages while profiting
substantially from his jewelry business
later that night Herman is surfing
through the internet when he stumbles
upon an online job vacancy it is from
the renowned artist devorah Klein who is
looking for a bold new Talent taking
this as a golden opportunity Hermann
visits devorah's office the very
following day there he meets with her
assistant who instructs him to present
his creation to her before presenting it
to devorah herself Herman then unveils a
globe which portrays the current
problems in the world unfortunately his
work meets rejection again that's not
art kid that's just a buzz kill despite
enduring a series of setbacks Herman
doesn't give up on his artistic
aspirations however this time things
take a different turn the next morning
Herman wakes up and hears someone
showering in his bathroom his mother
then shockingly reveals that she has
rented his room to a man because they
need money this clearly implies that she
doesn't support his dream or maybe it
implies that dreams don't pay bills with
no other option Herman reaches out to
his uncle Felix who is the same person
from the opening scene upon listening to
his struggles Felix understands
precisely what he needs he says that
Herman needs a private space where he
can work freely without any disturbances
Felix then offers Herman the opportunity
to stay in his old Studio a proposition
that initially fills Herman with joy
however his happiness is short-lived as
Felix charges a monthly rent of eight
hundred dollars what a steal that's
one-third of a shoebox in Toronto in the
following scene Herman having somehow
managed to complete his latest creation
attends devorah's art exhibition in an
attempt to make an impression he
presents his wall hanging artwork but
soon loses his control creating a
complete mess in the exhibition Hall
despite this mishap Herman requests
another chance asking for a two-week
time frame to create something
remarkable he even pledges to quit
everything if his art doesn't work out
hearing this devorah agrees she wants to
get rid of him as soon as possible
Herman then contacts Uncle Felix and
rents his old studio for a two-week
period he promptly visits the studio
situated behind an apartment building's
garbage area Guided by Felix's manager
Leila Herman enters a Dusty Antiquated
room containing a bed a mini
refrigerator and a crooked painting
nevertheless Herman pays a little
attention to these details and moves in
he purchases two weeks worth of food and
stores it all in the mini fridge without
delay he begins working on his mobile
art that very night days go by but
Herman struggles to make any progress in
his artwork this causes his frustration
and depression to gradually intensify
with patients like that Herman would
never make it on YouTube on the 13th day
of continuous failure he contemplates
giving up and even self-kill thoughts
cross his mind but just then the Crooked
painting catches his eye he attempts to
straighten it but it stubbornly tilts
back frustrated he tosses the painting
into a storage room shortly after
Hermann Witnesses in unusual phenomenon
a thread emerging from a small hole in
the room he pulls the thread revealing a
piece of paper with a message that reads
relax I can help puzzled Herman checks
the other side of the wall only to find
it completely sealed after receiving
several paper messages the hole spits
out a tiny jelly-like ball Herman fixes
it into his mobile structure and to his
astonishment it gets balanced having
finally completed his Masterpiece Herman
pays a visit to devorah's Residence the
following day but unfortunately she
refuses to Grant him entry claiming that
his Creations are always trashy this
completely devastates Herman and he
walks away almost in tears along his
path he hands over his creation to a
street side art Fender the latter puts
the artwork on display and surprisingly
within a few minutes several passersby
are attracted to it they even start an
impromptu auction among themselves
shortly after devorah herself shows up
and purchases the artwork with the
highest bid after this she apologizes to
Herman for her prior behavior and hires
him as her new artist filled with great
happiness Herman returns to his
temporary residence bursting with shouts
of Joy moments later a faint Whispering
female voice emanates from the hole
asking him whether everything went well
although initially scared Herman
eventually begins chatting with the
enigmatic voice and shares his happiness
The Voice reveals that she possesses a
lot more jelly balls that can help him
fulfill his long-awaited dream in return
he simply has to spend time with her
Herman agrees without any hesitation as
the days go by he establishes a good
relation with the mysterious hole and
spends most of his time inside the room
who knew that a simple hole could make a
man so happy in the midst of all this
Herman is time and again approached by
laylee who offers him pie she seems to
like him but Herman keeps her at Bay one
evening Herman attends devorah's
exhibition where his art is being
presented in front of wealthy clients
they seem to be so fascinated that one
of them purchases it for a massive sum
of fifty thousand dollars with this
success devorah assigns Herman to build
a batch of these masterpieces within a
month as she wants to host his solo
exhibition meanwhile at home Layla
knocks on Herman's door to offer him a
meal receiving no response she becomes
curious and Ventures into his room as
she explores the space she stumbles upon
the hole unable to resist her curiosity
she peers through it and discovers a
projection of Herman coming out from the
shower suddenly the hole spits out an
unfamiliar liquid into Layla's eye
prompting her to hastily run away from
there later on Herman returns home eager
to share the good news with the whole he
becomes so consumed by his Newfound
success that he doesn't pay much
attention to the origin of the whole or
the voice behind it Herman is now formed
a deep emotional and psychological
connection with the whole it becomes
evident that the whole yearns for his
presence whenever he goes out and often
fears abandonment The Voice expresses
that she doesn't want to be alone again
because cause it's unbearable upon
learning of her insecurity Herman
reassures her that he has no intention
of leaving however as more days pass
their relationship takes a dark turn one
day the whole is unable to produce the
jelly-like balls Herman inquires about
the matter to which the voice reveals
that she feels lonely he asks if there's
anything he can do to make her feel
better in response she shockingly says
that she wants to have intercourse say
no more says Hermann Herman firmly
declines but the hole reminds him of his
impending deadline also claiming that he
cannot create his art without the jelly
boss left with no choice Herman
reluctantly agrees and dips dong in the
art hole unbeknownst to Herman he is
secretly being watched by a guy named
Joel who is revealed to be devorah's
ex-best employee he was terminated after
Herman took his position because of this
an enraged Joel has been gunning for
revenge and now he knows that Herman
bones walls Days Later Herman completes
his next Masterpiece and presents it to
devorah who compensates him with a
substantial paycheck despite the
financial reward Herman doesn't look
happy due to the complex situation in
his life he is clearly seeking a normal
relationship and moreover a normal life
sensing his distressed devorah guides
him to a room expressing her attraction
to him she perceives them as an ideal
match with Herman being a talented
artist and herself a successful seller
their conversation soon takes a romantic
turn and they end up making out just
wait until they have a three-way with
the hole later in the evening Herman
returns to his room only to find that
the whole is already aware of his
involvement with devorah she confronts
him about it and Herman does not hide
anything he admits to having something
special with devorah and also asserts
that he cannot have a relationship with
the whole because she is not even human
following a brief argument Herman storms
out leaving the disheartened hole to add
more marks to the room's walls that same
evening The Voice contacts devorah
addressing herself as Herman's partner
and invites her to the old studio for
for a conversation the latter agrees and
arrives at the place to find a dimly lit
setup with a chair surrounded by candles
wasting no time the voice gets straight
to the point acknowledging the fact that
devorah is using Hermann solely for
money she then proposes a deal offering
exceptional artworks in exchange for
divorce staying away from Herman as
expected the cunning woman turns down
the offer and passes some hurtful
remarks towards the voice in response
the enraged hole sucks in all the oxygen
from the room causing devorah to pass
out shortly after Herman returns home
only to find a devorah lying on the
floor he somehow manages to bring her
back to her senses and drives her home
however devorah remains upset believing
that The Woman Behind the Walls is his
girlfriend later Herman is seen sitting
on a street bench reflecting on the
situation what am I gonna do about this
hole I can't get rid of it it's a hole
after a lot of deliberation he decides
to finally confess the truth to devorah
Hermann then goes to her place and
reveals everything about the mysterious
hole he also so admits that he doesn't
have real talent and that the Arts are
actually made by the whole regardless of
this Herman confesses his genuine love
for devorah and expresses his desire to
be with her forever surprisingly she
believes in him and accepts him as her
lover in the next scene Herman returns
to the studio room with the intent of
sealing all the holes as soon as he
enters he finds Joel who is trying to
use the hole to gain success for himself
seeing this Herman warns him to stay
away from it because he has no idea
about its consequences however Joel
disregards the warning and reaches out
to touch the hole this proves to be a
very bad decision as suddenly the hole
draws all of Joel's internal organs
inside resulting in his immediate demise
sucked them dry sensing the danger that
the hole possesses Herman starts to seal
off all the holes in the room one after
another amidst this The Voice
persistently attempts to persuade him
that devorah is not the right partner
for him and that she's merely using him
for financial gain however Herman
remains Resolute in his actions as he is
about to shut the final one an
unexpected Blow from behind renders him
unconscious after some time Herman
regains Consciousness only to find
devorah using a chainsaw to cut through
the wall puzzled he questions her
actions and she explains that she
intends to take the hole with her she
believes that by doing so she can create
her own masterpieces independently
without the need for anyone else not
even Herman this makes him realize that
the hole's warnings were true devorah
was only using him all this time Herman
then gets up and tries to stop her from
causing any further harm to the hole
amidst the brawl devorah accidentally
injures her own fingers with a chainsaw
prompting her to run away in pain
meanwhile the whole Cries Out nagony
which makes Herman feel very bad he
tries to comfort her assuring her that
he'll fix the damage but sadly the hole
loses a lot of blood through the walls
and passes away Herman is overwhelmed
with grief and guilt blaming himself for
the tragic outcome in the final scene
Herman prepares to move out of the
studio room before departing though he
cleans the blood from the walls and
Frames the hole properly as a final
tribute the moral of the story is
there's more to life than holes
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching